all right this is this is really weird
many of you have asked me to react to
this
podcaster joe rogan on whose program
i've appeared two times
now seems to essentially be endorsing
the dangerous radical unhinged
republican governor of florida ron
desantis now we're going to look at what
joe rogan said
but one of the important things to keep
in mind is
it's not just about oh rogan likes
desantis there's another aspect to this
which is rogan has been insisting that
he's like a progressive guy that his
policy ideas are most in line with
someone like a bernie sanders so
when you see someone who says i i really
am like a bernie guy in a lot of ways
when you see them say i like desantis
you have to ask questions like
is it not true that his policies most
align with bernie because bernie and
desantis are basically polar opposites
or does he not even really understand
what these people's policies are and
he's going on personality
i don't know the answer to any of these
questions but let's take a look at the
video clip here is rogan saying
desantis desantis didn't elon musk uh
come out recently for desantis yeah i
think ron desantis would work as a good
president i think i mean what he's done
for florida has been admirable look i
feel like i'm doing breaking news right
now that wasn't even on purpose
i feel like what he did for florida a
lot of people gave him a lot of grief
but ultimately he was correct he was
correct when it comes to like deaths he
was correct when it comes to protecting
our vulnerable populations he was
correct in terms of distribution of
monoclonal antibodies and he was furious
when the government tried to pull those
they were trying to pull very effective
treatments
you know he is just as a quick fact
check the government wasn't trying to
pull it what the government started to
realize was that its effectiveness was
diminishing and it may not be the best
course of action in some cases but it's
it's
it really has nothing to do with the
bigger picture here let's listen not
perfect he's a human being but
what he's done is stand up for freedoms
and people think that so this this was
some weird gaslighting [ __ ] that went on
where people equated freedom and saying
the word freedom to like right-wing
bigotry and hate is so strange well
sometimes that is exactly what they
meant by it so there's two parts okay
how did desantis do as florida governor
and then what about the prospect of ron
desantis as president of the united
states so
florida
despite being one of the top tourism
states in the country no thanks to
desantis like it's not because of
desantis that people go
to the gulf coast of florida to the
beaches to the atlantic coast of florida
to the beaches to the various um theme
parks and resorts in orlando to miami
beach that has nothing to do with the
sandisk florida has some great tourism
attractions and despite that florida
ranks 33rd in opportunity
26th in crime 41st in access to health
care 20
of floridians have no health insurance
and importantly that's all been pretty
similar with desantis as governor so
desantis has handed this tourism-rich
state
and he doesn't improve any of those
disastrous numbers
now in terms of the political positions
of ron desantis
first of all ron desantis is against
legalizing recreational marijuana
isn't this like a non-starter for rogan
rogan correctly supports legalization i
agree with rogan on that completely
the desantis view on that issue is so
antiquated wouldn't it be a
disqualifying position for someone like
joe rogan evaluating a candidate does
rogan know about that maybe he does
maybe he doesn't desantis is just
straight up against abortion he just
he's just against abortion period that's
it
another retrograde
antiquated uh worldview
um
rogan has daughters wouldn't he want in
certain situations that to be an option
at least if his daughters ever needed to
avail themselves of such a medical
treatment
it just does none of it's making any
sense and then of course you just go
deeper and desantis is wrong on you know
all but like a few issues that he comes
across desantis was against the iran
nuclear deal
he said it was a bad deal that would
degrade national security in fact the
deal worked really well
until donald trump stepped up and just
said we're out of the deal even though
iran didn't violate the deal i mean just
terrible what donald trump did the deal
was working fine it wasn't no deal is
perfect but it was working well
desantis is opposed to all gun safety
regulations the nra has raided desantis
as an a-plus now maybe rogan likes that
for me it's completely despicable
desantis called for a full and complete
repeal of obamacare with of course like
all of these republicans
no real substantive and plausible plan
for how to get people health care and as
i mentioned 20 percent of floridians
have no health insurance one out of five
floridians does not have health
insurance desantis was opposed to
deferred action for childhood arrivals
that's known as daca daca refers to
you're seven years old your parents come
to the united states illegally it's not
your fault you're seven you go where
your parents take you you then go to
school and then you go to high school
and
and what we should be doing is saying
this is really your country
you should be allowed to stay we're
going to defer action because you were a
childhood arrival
even many republicans are okay with that
desantis is against it and desantis has
a zero rating from the human rights
campaign for his voting record on
lgbt-related issues and legislation
everything i know about rogan is that
rogan is not homophobic and that rogan
believes that everybody should be
treated with dignity and respect and is
for gay marriage and on and on and
desantis has a zero rating so when it
comes to rogan on something like this
does rogan not know about the political
positions does rogan just go on
personality does rogan just go on
rhetoric i don't know the answer but it
is bizarre
for someone who says i'm like most
aligned with someone like bernie to say
desantis would be a good president it's
weird and i don't know what the
explanation is and i don't know how much
rogan knows about what ron desantis does
and stands for but that's where we are
right now and of course rogan's got a
huge audience there are people who will
hear this and go yeah i guess desantis i
don't know desantis is good as i've said
before desantis is like a trump
but he's less incompetent and that makes
him much more dangerous scary stuff